There we are.
Did you even notice I was gone?
Did you even know...
I
was gone?
But I didn't stream for a week!
Did you even notice?
Did you...
Find someone else to replace me?
No...
Maybe...
You left?
Yeah!
I'm sorry.
She's forgotten.
No!
Do you even know who I am?
Do you remember my name?
No!
Domenki?
We found Doki.
We set her marriage at bites!
Back up, sorry.
Wait, why are my arms down?
There we go.
Anyway, I know I gotta be big.
I'm not backing up.
And I'm not backing down!
Who is this girl?
Who is this?
Welcome back, maid channel.
Hey girl, it's your birthday!
Wait, hold on.
I didn't set my stuff up.
Domenki.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear A.
Grom!
Happy birthday to you!
Who
is this?
Say my name.
Minky!
I can't feel it.
Can't believe Doobi is gonna be at the concert.
Yeah!
I'm gonna be so hyped!
Thanks for the aqua soup.
My favorite zombie butler, Grom.
Minky!
I'm so obsessed with the Minky.
I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit.
I can't hear myself think.
I'm scared to do a backflip.
Do a flip!
Minto's cheeks are ponypony.
Minto, will you marry me?
Play.
I don't trust any requests now.
I have...
They're all just out of pity.
They're just out of pity now.
It's okay.
I...
I have accepted my fate.
I have...
I have accept...
I have accepted my fate.
Pity marriage is cool though.
It is.
Will you marry me and also panel with me?
Yeah, let's do the panel together, Ashes.
If you're just like, oh my gosh...
I'm a fleshy.
Well then, just get a VTuber involved.
I'll help you.
Wait, it's another birthday?
It was my birthday yesterday.
Fuck's sake!
I'm at hag age.
Happy birthday!
Happy old.
You're old.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday for fuck's sake.
Your name is funny.
Happy birthday to you.
I'm divorced.
It's not cool.
Wait, you and Nani got married?
Real?
I can't tell.
I don't...
There are so many...
I don't know what's ever going on.
I'm married.
But you can come on a date with my wife.
What day do you want to go to Disneyland?
No, I want to go...
I was in California this past week.
And I took a shuttle to my hotel.
And the driver was talking to me.
I was like, what's good to go around here?
And he was like, don't go to Disney.
It's overrated.
And Knott's Berry Farm?
Overrated.
There was like a mountain place.
I don't know...
Either of them.
Magic Mountain?
Magic Mountain.
What's good?
Oh, it's Six Flags.
Wait, so that means it probably has better roller coasters, right?
Also, Andreyko, thanks for the party.
Thank you.
Magic Mountain.
It has really good coasters.
That's what I like.
Oh my gosh, I saw today that...
That...
One of the Six Flags.
The one that has King Daka.
I can't remember the name of the Six Flags.
But they're getting rid of King Daka!
I'm so sad.
If you don't know King Daka, it's like...
I think it's the tallest roller coaster in the world.
Is it still the tallest?
Don't remember.
You look so damn cute.
Thank you.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
I am streaming tomorrow.
But I can sing it.
I can sing it.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Arsloat.
Like Arscloat, but Arsloat.
Happy birthday, Sloth.
Oh, Sloth.
Happy birthday, dear Sloth.
Happy birthday to you.
As someone that works at Six Flags with King Daka...
No, it is not.
Wait, they're not getting rid of it?
So the article was a lie?
Someone spreading lies on the internet?
Am I always facing sideways?
No, it's just because I'm reading chat.
I can look this way too.
Or I can look forward.
But I'm reading chat.
You guys are there.
I got cool stuff to share.
Oh!
Ace Combat 7, there's ace enemy nicknamed Jester.
Real name is Dice Insider, which you encounter on normal difficulty.
It is a reference to the first Top Gun movie.
Who's that?
Dice and the first Insider?
Who's in the...
Who in the first Top Gun?
Oh my gosh.
You guys have been thinking...
I've been thinking...
I want to do a...
Probably a members watch along.
But I want to do a...
I want to do a marathon of the first three Indiana Joneses.
I watched Indiana Jones again on the plane on the way home.
And I'm just like...
I keep watching the Temple of Doom over and over again.
I want to watch the other ones too.
I haven't seen it in years.
I want to do it.
I want to watch them.
There are only three Indiana Joneses.
Never seen two or three.
Maybe.
It's to prepare for the game.
Oh, is it to prepare?
Maybe.
When does the game come out?
Hold on.
Indiana Jones game.
Oh, I can pre-purchase it.
Wait, when does it come out?
December 9th!
Wait.
Soon.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I just finished watching the honeymoon stream.
I hope your cinnamon roll pants are okay.
It's okay.
Yeah, they're still stained.
I was so frustrated.
It's like...
I was just trying to work.
But I couldn't work, because everything was against me.
Shursti?
It's your birthday.
How many people's birthdays is it today?
Sang for me.
Can I request the MGS5 version?
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your skies stay blue, Shursti.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday everybody!
Today...
We're playing...
Halo Cure!
Look at the new menu!
New menu!
Look!
I'm adjusting stuff on my computer.
There we go.
Are you Yomu from Toho's Kaizen?
Are you ready for... Dang it.
I'm ready.
Ready.
I'm ready for anything.
I like how it's 0.7.1731710129.
Feels like I just docked somebody.
But...
Yeah!
A cast to join.
What?
I'm one of the few, if not the only Wisp that was not attracted to Fem Nani.
I should ban that phrase in my chat.
I should...
I'm sick of it!
Don't become addicted to the minigames.
I don't know much about what's all in here.
I've tried to avoid everything.
So I'm excited...
...to see everything!
What do we start with?
Oh my gosh, I don't even know.
Do we start with...
Oh!
New everything!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, are there new upgrades and stuff?
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh, there's all new stuff!
New look.
Okay, well all my stats are maxed out.
So...
Fan letters.
Unlocks fan letters.
All fan types can drop fan letters which grant permanent boosts.
And yeah, you can hold items now.
Let's see.
Oh, this is the eliminate.
This is the hold.
Allows weapons and items to be disabled in the armory.
Armory?
Hold?
Unlocks support items, allowing the use of support abilities chosen before a stage.
Fans have a chance to drop hollow house materials.
That's so big!
Hold!
373k gold, Binto Rich.
I've been fishing a lot.
Hold on.
Oh, this is the armory.
Yeah.
I still have more stuff to find.
My best combo is like 98 or something.
I don't know.
I remember I got close to...
I got close to 100.
A whole new line.
Hold on, I always choose a Kiwawa.
I can't tell if the music is different or not.
I always turn it off because I play while I do other things, you know?
Look at my little workers.
They're working hard.
They better not be tired, I swear.
Give me my money.
Thank you, workers.
It's the same?
Oh, okay.
Simponi.
Thanks for the five gufton.
I think they're all exhausted.
Oh god, I have 30 onions.
I was about to be like, uh-oh.
More onion!
This guy is a newbie.
Yeah, I have a bunch.
Okay.
Oh, you're also tired.
More onion!
Yeah.
You can get more workers?
Yeah, but I'm stingy.
I don't want to spend my money on food.
I don't...
I'm stingy and I don't want to keep planting.
Why isn't this area expanded?
Smash boo!
Thanks for the five gufton.
Here, hold on.
Let me show you.
I have a lot of fish.
But also...
I wanted to show you guys my golden koi fish that I got.
My first... It was my first golden anything.
I wonder if I sold everything, how much money would I have?
Would I have enough for the golden rod?
No, not quite.
Not quite.
It's not money, it's sand.
Then you convert it to money.
Or you can.
Or I could... I gotta buy this golden rod.
Yummy sand.
I want the golden rod!
But I also want more money.
Hold on, I'm just gonna do one fish.
Okay.
Just one.
Puffer fish.
Then they're making me money.
Okay, let's see what else is around in here, because they...
What's this?
North hollow house, south...
Sikila's fort?
Oh wait, cute girl ahead.
East?
Cute girl?
Sorry, that's west.
Other way.
Cute girl!
You didn't have to say anything.
In here?
Is it hot?
Oh no!
Oh no, is that the deadbeat up there?
A tower of suffering.
Oh.
Oh no.
They just put Jump King in the cave!
Oh my god.
Wait, I think I'm stuck.
Okay, good, good.
No way.
I've never been able to beat Jump King.
Could I beat this instead?
I wonder.
Wait, why can't I...
Where is it?
Why isn't it not jumping anymore in the direction?
There we go.
Is this...
Does this count as a...
Does this count as hollow cure anymore?
I don't know.
Does this count anymore?
God, I keep dying here.
Oh no.
This is messed up.
I made it, I made it, I made it.
Which way is up?
I think I can go either way.
I'm feeling lucky.
I think they said QA took 3 to 4 hours...
for this.
Playtesters took 3 to 4 hours to beat this.
I was supposed to have two meetings tonight.
Well, okay, one of my meetings got cancelled.
And then, oh gosh, I'm such an idiot.
I put my other meeting as tonight, but it was actually last night.
And so I was just like, you know...
I'll play.
No!
I'll play, but you know like...
I'll only be able to play for so much.
Now I have all the time in the world.
Who is the cute girl though?
Who is the cute girl?
I must wonder.
Yes.
It's at the top.
What, do we get to the top and there is like a mirror?
It's just like, you're the cute girl.
You're the cute girl.
Cute girl at bottom right of screen.
Yeah, QIY is right there.
The girl reading this.
I don't trust you guys.
We got to go through there.
Welcome back, it was my birthday yesterday.
Here is a present.
Happy belated birthday!
Thank you for the pink.
Are you saying Miami didn't draw a cute girl?
I'm just saying.
I'm saying.
You can call a yummy mama's art cute.
But also cuteness is of character.
And I'm not cute in character.
I'm spooky.
Obviously.
OK, I give up.
I think... Wait, let me out.
Let me out of here.
Oh, escape.
Place check point.
You have to pay the place check point.
No way.
That's silly.
I have no patience for...
Jump King.
Reading this is the last achievement I need.
In level... And they are in level coins only?
No way.
Where are we going now?
To the forge?
I saw that... Oh my goodness.
I saw this in the trailer, right?
That there is just Minecraft.
Oh my god.
I almost got it full.
Oh my gosh, I took down... I took down the rock and a tree grew in its place.
Amazing.
This is just stick.
Level 3?
Oh they have different levels.
OK, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in.
I need to be stronger.
Wait a second.
It didn't go all the way to the end, did it?
There we go.
Oh,
a tree grew in its place.
Oh, this one is easy.
One hard wood.
Upgrade.
Let's upgrade.
Craft?
Old... Oh no.
How do I make a nice axe?
Oh, I need to... What's commission?
Oh, I can make shields?
Why do I need a shield?
It's kind of scary.
What's this?
Oh, iron.
Iron.
I'm always just a little bit off.
I'm always just a little bit off!
Talk to her for explanation?
OK.
Help me.
Help me, Kyla.
I'm helping take care of the forge here while my... Oh wait, that's not Kyla.
Oh my god, it's her sister.
Oh my god.
Just kidding.
You can craft tools and other items here that might help you on your adventures.
You need to go gather materials.
If you go further down, you'll find a bunch of trees and rocks.
Gather a bunch and bring them to me.
I'll craft whatever you want.
You can even make better tools to help gather stronger material.
Tools have different stats.
Powers are hard.
Strike how many times you get to swing your tool.
Gather will increase the amount of resources you gather.
Precision is how easy it is?
OK.
We offer commissions.
Oh, if you bring the required materials, I will give you lots of money.
C is pronounced like CH.
Oh, so like Chiquita.
Thank you.
What perks do we get for marrying Minto?
Can we get to cuddle your little snakes?
No.
Snake?
As soon as I get little snake, I lock him in a cabinet.
And he never leaves.
Shakira!
Shakira, Shakira.
I don't...
If you were to have a Minto to marry, your perks would be...
You cook.
And I eat it.
Fish.
And...
What else?
Can we pet your cats?
Yeah!
Wow, Johnny!
Thank you for the 50...
Thank you, thank you.
Ectoplasm.
That... Oh my god, blood loss has become exhausted.
His name is so metal.
What are they adding you to holocure?
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm not in hololive.
That would be scary if I was in there.
Why?
Deal.
If you don't get the item because it is ours...
Oh, but you don't get the item because it's ours.
I hope my sister won't get mad if we pay too much.
Go get some materials.
What else can we...
Oh, I thought this was sparkling.
Is this diamond?
It's lead.
I mean... Oh, it is lead.
Oh my gosh, it's so fast.
This is only level 2.
I thought it was... Look, it looks like it was sparkling, right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, whoops.
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, I was paying attention and I suck.
I suck.
I got one plank.
Okay, give me some stick.
Oh, I can't even... I can't even get this correctly.
Every character has a new outfit.
Okay, I know.
I need to actually play the game.
Because there's new people we need to get.
Actually, I need to pull the gacha.
So I need to make... Well, I think I have enough money for gacha.
3 out of 3, Ms. Tatsumawashi.
She's blind.
Does that make me cuter if I'm blind?
Everybody loves a stupid gal.
I don't want to be dumb anymore.
Look at my Oshi.
She's so stupid.
Dumber than the rock.
That was even level 1, I think.
I'm gonna get out of the way.
I can't see.
What's this?
Oh, Iroh.
If you're blind, how can you see a snake?
That's like a sixth sense, you know?
I have a sixth sense for my Oshis, I think.
Well, I mean, I'm a ghost, so it's kind of a sixth sense anyway.
I don't know how to describe it.
I can just feel when my Oshi is around.
If I don't have my glasses on or something, but I see my Oshi on a screen...
And I can't see anything and they're just a blob...
Usually I can still identify them.
Give me a level 2.
Okay, I need more sticks.
You can smell them.
Will you be my Kamiyoshi?
Sure.
I feel like... I feel like I've never felt...
The way that I have...
In this past week.
I think you guys have made me...
I don't know how to say.
I think I...
Are you feeling love?
The opposite!
I don't know.
I was like...
Okay!
Oh, I need to pay attention.
You guys are such jerks.
Making me feel such a way.
It's like...
What is this?
Give me money.
Hit this critical spot...
To polish and increase the quality of the item.
What's the critical spot?
Here?
Did I make it right?
We are your jerks.
You won't know until you hit it.
Oh, the higher noise.
Alright, let's try this one.
Am I making money?
She's quoting Ace Attorney.
No one has tried to get to the top so far?
Really?
I have all night.
I have all night, baby.
I was gonna have some meetings and now I have all night, baby.
Oh, I gotta mine some more.
We gotta get to level 2.
Giving my wishing money.
Thank you.
It's so relaxing in the hollow house, so it's just kind of nice.
Yay!
Higher tier!
My wife Otacon never says she hates me and always has relevant and helpful advice.
Who are you?
Chovek, are you a snake?
Also, why are you awake?
You're like never up this... It's too late for you.
Go to bed.
Welcome back.
Thanks, Osni.
I think that I do in fact know everything.
Just because I have Doki's Oshi mark before yours doesn't mean I love you any less.
If I could have two Kamiyoshis, I would.
I appreciate it.
Wait.
Well, craft.
Insufficient... Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I need more stuff.
Basic prism.
What are these?
Blocks up to 7 damage from attack.
So this is stuff for like the game game?
My first one is JPEG.
Yeah, we know, Nan.
We know.
Oh my god!
Still got three, baby.
The actual game.
We'll get there!
Okay, fine.
I'll leave this for now.
We gotta go check out...
Which way was...
Oh, okay.
This way.
West is the casino.
Here comes the real games, baby!
Wait, what's down here?
What is this?
Remnants of a lost civilization?
Here we go!
Oh my gosh, following my...
My somewhat sister.
Let's go gambling!
Wait, I can talk?
I only have 100 gold carats, but...
Ina has a thousand gold carats.
Rock, paper, scissors!
Scissors!
Give me the money.
Rock, paper, scissors!
Come on!
Rock, paper... Wait, lost all our Usa coins and ran home crying.
Scissors!
Rock, paper, scissors!
Oh my god, wandering taco, please.
Lend me your strength.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
I need scissor 61!
OK.
Fall in on!
What do you mean you took 296?
I only had 100!
Wait, am I in debt?
What does this mean?
Maximum bet.
How do I make more money?
Wait.
Make...
Convert...
Peco chips.
What's the prizes?
Holo coin prizes.
Definitely not a scam item.
Drink.
You will only waste your chips from buying this, actually.
But
it...
But it's...
Usada drink?
Just saying.
I don't have enough money anyway though.
Random assortment of fish.
Trails.
You guys, we have to get the cat!
Oh my god!
We can get a fucking monkey!
What?
I want the monkey!
Minky!
Oh, can I name him too?
I wonder.
Increase...
Gosh, there's so much here!
Oh my gosh, there's so much here.
Oh no.
Are you OK?
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You don't have enough money for me.
What's this?
Higher, lower.
What's a higher, lower?
This is a simple game of higher, low.
First we draw a left card, face up.
All you have to do is guess whether the right card is higher or lower.
If you guess right, you win.
Also option of switching left card.
You only do that once in a game until you cash out or lose.
Higher, lower.
Nah, I want to go with blackjack.
Blackjack is basically the same.
What's this?
I'll lose all my money there.
Fight pit?
Oh my god, blood loss.
Blood loss.
Is he training?
Training?
It says it costs nothing.
I'm confused.
Send him to battle.
Into the...
I'll put it in the beginners.
Beginners.
Alright, blood loss.
You got this.
Wait, do I have to fight?
Which one is my guy?
Oh, there he is.
Get his ass!
Attack!
Special?
Get the item!
Special!
Where are you going?
Oh my god, he's winning.
You guys, he's actually winning.
Attack!
Yeah, kick their asses!
Blood loss!
Cause them to have blood loss, not you!
Get up!
My guy is almost dead.
How much money do I make from that?
What?
My guy came in second!
He came in second.
How much do I make?
Blood loss.
Second is first loser.
I have to buy out again?
I have to buy more?
Okay.
That's okay.
We'll go with it all in blackjack.
You guys want me to try the math quiz?
Gura.
Normal.
Challenge.
Endless.
Will you guys help me?
No help.
Yeah, I expected that.
Wait, how do I get a...
Eighteen.
Four.
Eight.
Eighteen?
It's eighteen, right?
Thirty-eight?
I can't reach him.
Get out of the way!
I can't reach him!
Stop!
I can't get to him.
I might be cooked.
Guys...
I can't reach...
This game is sabotaging me!
Thirty...
Six?
Six plus three is nine.
Okay, I got it.
Five?
Yeah!
Eighteen.
What
the...
Oh, six by six.
I was thinking of six by three again.
Thirty-six.
I can't get to him though.
This game is rigged.
The house always wins.
Move, twenty-five, move!
Yeah.
No cheating.
I use my fingers, it's not cheating.
Forty-five.
Because four plus five is nine.
You guys said no help and here you are in the chat.
You guys are...
Yay!
Can I do the slots?
Slots?
Each play costs ten chips.
Spin the slot to start.
Press the stop three times until they are all stopped.
Row or diagonal.
If you are lucky, the machine will go into fever.
When a mini-game appears, simply mash the button as fast as you can to win extra.
Okay, let's try it before I go to the...
Oh my gosh, there is so much.
Spin!
Stop!
Ah dang it.
Spin.
Stop.
Stop!
Stop it!
Ah dang it.
Stop.
Stop it!
Ah dang it.
Stop it.
Stop.
Five more times.
We're fine, we're fine.
Nobody has won this before anyway though, right?
Stop it.
Chocolate bunny!
Stop it!
Ah, dang it.
Stop it.
So close to the seven, seven, seven.
So close.
Stop it.
Stop it!
Stop it, stop it, stop it!
We got ten.
Stop, stop, stop!
Ah, dang it.
Stop, stop!
Stop!
I can't stop winning!
Stop, stop!
Stop it!
Dang it.
Stop, stop!
Stop it!
I can't stop winning!
Have I made a net positive?
I don't even know at this point.
Stop, stop!
Stop it!
Dang it.
Stop, stop!
Stop it!
Dang it.
Stop, stop!
I think you're breaking even.
Alex,
happy birthday!
Another year with our favorite silly ghost.
You start at 1100.
Stop, stop!
This could be it, guys.
This could be the big money.
This could be...
Big...
Money!
Ah, dang it.
Stop, stop!
Stop it!
Guys, tell me when to stop it.
Tell me!
Tell me when to stop it!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Now?
Stop now?
No!
Ah, dang it.
Oh, no, no, I wanted a kick.
No!
Stop, stop, stop.
Ah, okay.
We want our money back though.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, I got some...
Kick it.
Oh, I thought kick meant like...
I thought...
Wait, huh?
I thought kick meant leave.
Oh, just kidding.
Anyway, I don't care about that.
What's over here?
We know this is blackjack.
What's this one?
Sorry.
Double blackjack.
Okay.
And this one is what?
Roulette.
Put in the chips in the color slot.
Each slot has a different payout, but it's multiplier.
You put in ten chips in pink, you'll win back a hundred and ten chips.
Sounds like I'm scamming them.
Oops, sorry.
Sorry, I accidentally clicked out of the game.
I don't care.
Let's play blackjack.
Guys, I forgot how to play blackjack.
No, no, no.
I didn't.
I can bribe them.
I was watching your re-debut and I missed...
That I miss that you're great and your singing is just divine, exquisite, ten out of ten.
And you're stinky.
Hey!
Goose, thank you.
Oh, you're drunk.
Don't super chat drunk.
I think I should hit.
Because otherwise he's just gonna win.
Hit!
All in,
baby.
Yippee!
Play again.
This is a little terrifying.
What happens if I bri...
Oh.
Spend 25% of current bet to increase chance of bribing the dealer.
If successful, the next draw will get to blackjack.
If possible, or a ten.
I love blackjack.
Oh my god, I love blackjack.
I'll super chat while I'm not drunk in the future.
Hit.
This is the thrill, everybody.
This is the thrill.
Oh, hit.
I wish there was an all in.
There should be a double down.
Stay, but that's no fun.
If I...
If I don't...
Where's the...
I mean...
We gotta...
Hit!
I was just alive!
Why?
Because that's the thrill of the game!
Why else do you think I love blackjack so much?
This is the thrill, everybody.
This is the thrill.
You don't understand!
You don't understand.
Cowards won't get it.
Cowards won't...
Hit.
It's okay, this is the thrill.
Always hit.
Hit.
This is so much fun.
Oh my gosh, this is everything that I love.
Hit!
You
son of a bitch!
What are you doing here?
I lost all my chips, everybody.
I just want to keep playing blackjack, but I have to save my money for also gacha.
What's... Wait, build mo...
Oh, that's for the house.
Just kidding.
I'm ready.
Wait, this table is bad.
It's this table that's good.
Cowards wouldn't get it.
Soon to be a homeless ghost.
It's the real thrill though.
It's the real thrill.
Don't you think?
I got enough for the monkey, only to lose it trying to get more coins.
But I got it back.
See?
You're not allowed to go to Vegas, Minto.
Probably not.
I'm probably wanted there.
Oh my gosh, I love blackjack.
Okay, confirm bet.
Alright, we got this, guys.
Believe.
I want to hit so bad.
Okay, I'll stand.
I felt no satisfaction in that whatsoever.
I felt no satisfaction in that whatsoever, by the way.
Minto is so cute.
I don't know why she doesn't get more proposals.
Sorry, I can't.
I already have a 100% real wife.
And you'd gamble my life savings.
Stop bragging.
I already have a wife.
You mean our wife.
Okay, one more.
One more.
See, when you're on 16, it's really just kind of like a...
What do I do?
This is where the real thrill happens.
Wait, huh?
Oh, it turned to 13.
Oh, we would have lost.
That's the real thrill, baby.
How long have I been playing blackjack for?
Sorry.
Should we go do some gacha?
I wanna play more blackjack.
Oh, my guys are tired.
Okay, I'll go feed them.
I'm getting lightheaded.
Hold on, I need to eat some rice.
Winners never quit and quitters never win.
Exactly.
Give me my money.
Just add a 1 to this blackjack.
Wait, can't you...you can't do...
Why didn't you add the 1?
Why didn't you add it?
Can't you do custom numbers?
Not in the budget.
I sound so greedy.
Why didn't you donate a dollar to me?
Oh, my god.
How dare you.
Pass my PhD thesis to birds.
Oh, my gosh.
Algernon, congratulations!
Bust.
Bust!
That's the thrill of it.
Alright.
Let's go to shop and character gacha.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Wow, it's so crazy.
So...
That's...
I like all the new ones.
The new...
I like the whole design here.
It's so nice.
Shall we fantasy?
Oh, yeah.
The new outfits.
That's right.
Kiwawa new outfit.
Oh, my gosh.
I love this one.
Is this the space outfit?
I want it.
I want...
Well, this one was already in there, right?
But I want it.
I want it.
What if I just like...
Ten time gacha.
Let's see what we get.
A single...
Just a single outfit.
Oh, wait.
You guys can't see it.
Sorry.
I got the Ame outfit.
Yeah, I'll make myself small.
Ame outfit.
Hold on.
I have a Katsukare.
Today.
Again.
We got two outfits, actually.
Oh, three outfits.
Oh, my god.
Look at us go.
Cat Wawa.
I was all time top five with Azuki.
FWR coin farmer character.
Bald Minto said she don't mind out.
I'm not bald.
Do you still want some tips for farming coins?
Sure.
I'll take it.
Sorry, I got so hungry all of a sudden.
I just gotta...
Let me have a little bit of a bite.
Unlucky.
Pekora is good for farming?
Okay, let's try it.
Let's try...
I could buy it, but there's no fun in that.
Wait.
Wow, they even added the new Chuni one.
They hate me.
Wait.
No Gauze.
Oh, but we got Gauze the mermaid.
No Gauze Fauna.
So sad.
Witch hat is Gauze Fauna?
Fauna sees hat.
I
thought the witch outfit...
No, Gauze Fauna...
Has the short hair.
Long and short.
Oh my god, I never even realized.
What?
I never even realized it.
They added so many outfits.
It's a toggle.
How exciting.
She doesn't know everything about Fauna, big fan.
How dare she claim to love Fauna...
When she doesn't even know...
Her cup size.
I felt those bad boys with my bare hands...
Was able to measure the circumference based upon the shadows from the sun.
What was I saying?
Okay, anyway.
We must...
Pull.
It's a Gisado!
Actually, we got a good amount of...
Good amount of outfits.
Nice.
Okay, one more.
No new outfits.
One more, one more.
Why no new outfits?
Outfits.
Yeah, I got the Fauna outfit.
Because she has the...
So cute.
But I don't have this one.
The kimono one.
Use tears?
No, that's no fun.
Okay, one more.
One more.
We got Iris outfit.
Okay, let's see.
How much do you bet we can get all four of them...
In one go?
No gacha, no live.
Zero?
Why don't you have faith in me?
Four dupes?
Come on.
Man, Noel just kind of...
Did you change your YouTube channel icon?
I noticed it was different during your hiatus.
No.
It's my birthday weekend.
Oh my gosh!
Chikara Chikara!
Happy early birthday.
Welcome back.
Hope you had a fantom-tastic week.
You too!
Wait, who am I missing?
Pekora!
Oh, it has a little check mark.
That's so cute now.
So these everybody didn't have just two outfits?
Oh, I love this Peko outfit though.
So cute.
Pen Peko.
We got her this time.
Gifted.
Oops, I'll Peko.
Peko, Peko, Peko.
Yay!
All four in one go.
Draw a heart.
That's the Minto way.
The Minto luck.
I just got back from my trip to Japan and changed your opening...
And you changed your opening screen to Akihabara.
Yeah, I love Akihabara.
And my ending screen is also Akihabara.
All Akihabara.
I should try...
I want to...
Okay, hold on.
Let's try and get all the outfits.
Wait, I'm missing...
Marine's and Pekora's second outfits.
I think we can get it in five.
Has Mint seen Marine's new skill yet?
I haven't seen anything yet.
Okay, fine.
Oh, we have a whole other...
We have a whole other generation to do.
How much do you want to say I can get all five in one pull?
Yeah, no spoilers everybody.
You're kind of bad at this.
It's...
It's gacha.
How do I...
How am I bad at gacha?
What do you...
Is that a skill thing?
Okay.
Oh wait, I want to see their other outfits.
Stop, stop.
Oh, I like this one.
Is that her pajamas?
Oh, I was hoping the second outfit would be the dragon.
That one.
I love the short hair Luna.
Okay.
Here we go.
All five in one.
I'm not looking, I'm not looking, I'm not looking, I'm not looking, I'm not looking.
Can I get all five in one?
I was so close!
No way!
Toa-sama.
Why?
I was so close.
Alright, one more.
The game was like...
You wanted Kanatan?
Okay, sorry.
My bad.
How is this possible?
Not everybody they added, right?
It's everybody they added, right?
Okay, you need to buy the new things from the shop.
You're right!
These, the holds.
Hold, hold, hold, hold, hold.
Allows weapons to be disabled in the armory.
Do I need this?
Let's have a...
Oh yeah, yeah, buy that.
Buy the fan letter.
Buy this.
It's not everything, right?
I probably should grab for now.
Looks like it helps you tailor your build more.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't really...
I guess if I'm like trying for a certain achievement or something.
I can show you my guys on my...
Oh wait, what's the new achievements?
Where?
Oh here.
Achievements.
Oh, fan letters.
There's 82 of them!
Oh my goodness.
See, I haven't defeated stage 4 yet.
Now there's even a stage 5!
Maybe we'll try for stage 4 today.
And complete the armory.
I haven't done that yet.
But I feel like I've gotten a good amount of stuff.
There's like some of these that I haven't done.
That I still need to do.
Win a worker race.
What's this?
Is that...
Is that a skill?
Get 100,000 USA chips.
Get a pet.
I'm gonna do that!
Win a jackpot!
Sell 10 stamps in one run.
Is this new?
Is this Narissa's feather?
Clear stage mode.
Run after dying 3 times with chicken feathers.
New items.
Wait, what are these ones?
No Elp.
That's...
You make no sense!
I'm asking who are they associated with?
Oh, top is the promise tiara.
Oh, cute!
And then this one is which?
Mirika.
Oh!
I see, I see, I see.
Clear the tower.
I think you need more money than that.
For clearing the tower of suffering, I'm just saying.
I see, I see, I see.
I've got 82 out of 200.
I've got 40% complete.
It's not so bad, I suppose.
Not so bad, I suppose.
Look, they're so shiny.
Look!
Oh my gosh, we have the whole...
We have the whole cast.
Yippee!
Alright, let's actually play the game.
Who should I play as first?
Roll slots.
Deal 1000% damage to all targets if jackpot is rolled.
Wait, I have to gacha in this too?
Marine.
All weapon sizes increased.
Summon a number of Flare Blasters that shoot wide beams at targets to deal 300% damage.
Cocoa transforms into her true dragon form for 8 seconds.
Slowly heal 10%.
Towa quotes a heavy machine gun and gains 100 ammo.
Fires multiple...
This one reminds me of...
There's another thing that you have like...
What is it?
I can't remember.
There's another one that you have...
Like a certain amount of ammo with.
Hello!
Welcome to membership, aren't you?
Fires multiple beams in all directions to deal rapid damage.
Create a concert of music notes around Luna, dealing constant damage.
Cute.
Okay, I guess...
Some people said... A lot of people said Marine.
Oh, the Reine Punch!
Yes, that's what I was thinking of.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the Reine Punch.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Marine has the funniest skills?
I'll go with endless mode then.
We'll go... Actually, well, maybe I'll go stage mode so I can try...
Everybody out.
We'll just do the office.
No L.
Where
did I get these from?
Control for your support item.
Oh, thank you.
Dash is fun.
Gains invincibility for one second.
Yeah.
Oh, in the shop.
Thank you for the 50 gifts inside!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, thank you so much!
I guess I'll try... Wait, so if I...
Use it, do I lose it?
Like, rather, is it one time use?
I like her vibe in YouTube clips.
Of who?
Marine?
Oh, it has a cooldown.
Ah, I see, I see.
It was my birthday on the 11th and I thought I'd take this opportunity to thank you and all the Wisps for the amazing time I've had in this community.
Oh, Nashi!
So grateful to be here with you all, keep being awesome.
You!
I'm sorry I missed your birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Nashi!
Happy birthday!
Also, I'm gonna call you out, Sanada.
You don't have to be rude.
I'm asking if a support item, I have to buy it each time I want to use it in a stage.
I can read the yellow here.
Cooldown 10 seconds.
I can read.
I just wanted to see if it was... You buy it every time.
Gosh.
No need to be rude.
Just select and use.
Let's try it.
What's her...
Oh, she's got like a range.
Oh my gosh, and it's homing.
That's insane.
What the...
That's actually... Wow, that's so nice.
Oh my gosh, we already got a sticker.
Let's go.
I never get stickers so early.
Gain of Lust gauge?
The gauge increases slowly near enemies...
Or when hit.
A max gauge.
Marine reaches her climax.
Healing 20%.
Is this why you guys wanted me to play as Marine first?
Oh, what the...
Oh, that's the material.
Oh my gosh.
They dropped the material.
That's so nice.
Wait, we gotta get closer.
No!
This way.
I wanna go this way.
Oh my gosh.
Pistol shoots two shots.
Let's go.
Wait, I didn't read what the Pirate's Captain did.
My bad.
I didn't read it.
I'm too... Wait, what?
I'm too much...
Too old to support my Oshis openly day to day.
Can only really do it at home via super chats.
Long story short, I'm glad you're here.
What?
What are you talking about?
Thank you for the Haka Super.
Thank you!
When collecting Holo Coins, increase crit by 1% for 5 seconds, up to 10%.
Targets hit by skills...
Targets hit by skills has a 10% chance to drop additional...
Mine.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I kinda want them to hit me though.
Nice.
I wanna level up my skills first.
Okay!
Mint Phantom would have the same ability as Les Gage, except it's called Freak Gage.
Yeah.
Say the line, Mint.
The famous Mighty in Quote.
Ahoy?
Oh my god, more Lust.
Yeah, I think I'd have a Freak Gage.
I hate this.
But I hate that it's so accurate, probably.
Did we just take off our...
We just woohooed in the game!
It became The Sims for a moment!
Dr. Worm!
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
We woohooed in the game.
I like Mighty's Elage, because she's got like the homing and then also the...
She's got the pistol and then also the slashy slash.
It's so nice.
Thanks Kay for the update and thank you for the whole Holocure team as well.
Stupid idiot being like...
Gave us like a bajillion minigames in one.
Come here.
Come here everybody.
Oh, it hurts so good.
Oh god, why is she naked all of a sudden?
Oh wait, what's my...
If a target is within 80...
Within 80 pixels for more than one second, they gain a debuff that reduces defense.
Are you calling her stinky?
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm excited for all the new... What's it called?
All the new collabs too.
Oh my god, take my stench!
Take it!
Oh,
you know what?
I'll take it.
Oh wait, let's try my special.
Oh, just kidding.
Here we go!
Oh my god.
Cute!
Hold on, I'm trying to bust this open.
There we go.
Nice, we're almost to full.
Upgrading my stench.
This is so messed up.
Oh, money!
Give me the money!
Wait, oh, I'm like dying for real.
There we go.
Awakened.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, why can't I hit him?
Am I stupid?
There we go.
Flower.
Take my stench.
Out of context Minto.
Yeah, drink some water.
Smelly, smelly, smelly, smelly.
Take it.
I'm so used to... How do I... What's the range on it now?
I'm so used to playing this game off stream now.
I'm like used to just not talking while I play it.
Oh yeah, the more coins.
More coins.
The smell range is crazy.
Yeah, actually...
This is why I...
Actually, last time I...
Last time I saw Matara...
She left like a bunch of her stuff with me.
And one of it was her perfumes.
But I really like it.
I told her.
She was like...
She was like, you can get rid of all the other stuff, but keep the perfume.
It smells so good.
I've been using it.
Okay, hold on.
So, oh yeah, I have all these collabs now, by the way.
Like I've gotten more of them.
But what are the new ones?
I guess...
I wouldn't know, because I don't have any of the new... I gotta get new items first, huh?
Why do our noses run when our feet smell?
How long can you go without talking on stream?
Do you wanna see?
No.
You need the new weapon from beating level 5.
Yeah, I need the new weapon.
I haven't even beat level 4!
Okay, after this, after this we'll try and beat level 4.
Even if it's not a new...
Oh wait, where are these hearts coming from?
Where are the hearts coming from?
Even if it's not a new character.
What the...
Minto smells like Matora.
So if she calls me smelly, she's basically just calling herself smelly.
You know what, we'll do this.
That actually works out.
She's like my stinky GF, well...
You know what, I am gonna get the limiter.
Because I'm lazy.
I don't know how to describe it though.
The perfume.
I don't even know the name of it.
I love the smell of mint.
Mint peppermint.
I could tell you guys and then you could get the same thing and be like...
I'm using the same perfume as my...
Oh my gosh, and then if you get my dakimakura you could spray it on there.
And then it would really...
Really smell like it.
Yes, I will buy it.
Okay, I'll DM it to you, Oimo.
I don't know the name of it.
It's in my bathroom, so...
Speaking of Matara, did you unblock her?
Oh yeah, I did unblock her.
Unfortunately.
Yeah, I unblocked her, unfortunately.
But I haven't followed her.
It's really just a...
How do I say?
It's a matter of pride now.
Who follows who first.
Upgrade.
I need more haste.
Nice.
Yummy.
Does her perfume smell like teen spirit?
Surely there is a perfume called teen spirit, right?
Surely.
There has to be.
Pride is at stake, exactly.
You won't see me.
You won't see me following her first, I'll tell you that.
Teen spirit is a deodorant.
It is?
It's a deodorant.
No way.
Wait, so this...
What's Mari...
Where is my stamps?
Hurt me good.
Where is my... Oh, there it is.
Let's just keep upgrading this and then I'll combo them.
I need more lust.
Wait, my team feels so broken.
It's awesome.
Minto doesn't smell like mint?
There goes my plans.
What are you talking about?
What plans?
There is an achievement for 500 pick-up range.
Heart, meat, kettle.
My re-debut won't be that hype phantom.
Yeah, but that's... My re-debut is not a whole ass game, OK?
My re-debut is not a game.
Peko and Coco are the broken ones.
Really?
I haven't even reached it.
I haven't even reached it yet.
Let's just grab all of these for now.
Chanceler!
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
There was a game though.
It's different.
Thank you for reminding me.
I have to do stuff for that tonight.
I have to message people.
I think I'm gonna post...
I want to have more people to have a chance to be in the game.
So I might do like a...
Have like, you know...
What's the word?
Like I might post on Twitter if any like...
Other Vtubers...
Want to be in it and then have it like a random chance.
Rather like...
Cause then I could be like... Go to someone like kind of small, you know?
And then they could be in the game.
So...
I was joking with the sweepstakes.
Oh, I didn't even see you post that.
I didn't even see you post that.
No, I just like, you know, like say like any...
Any...
Any Vtubers that want to be in, just reply to my post and then I pick someone at random.
I mean, it's not a huge thing.
It's not like it's the greatest thing.
You know, like it's just a small little game.
But I figure, you know, it might be kind of fun for some people to be like...
I'm in the game!
I don't know.
Maybe someone would want to be in it.
So...
Okay.
Give me my anvil.
Give... Where is my anvil?
Where is...
Oh!
Money.
Money, baby.
Wait.
What is this one?
This is collector stamp.
If a target is defeated within 2 seconds after being hit by this weapon, they have a 1% chance to drop a stamp.
But may drop a mushroom.
What?
Oh, it's already maxed.
New stamp!
What's a mushroom?
What if they drop the mushroom?
Drop a mushroom!
There it is.
Kinako?
I got a meal!
That's so crazy.
Oh my gosh, they dropped a stamp!
Increase attack size.
I want to see the other one.
Ow.
I'll just go with the Asakoko.
Mint Phantom.
That's my name.
I thought you guys forgot about me.
I thought you guys didn't like me anymore.
I thought you guys forgot all about me.
I dreamt about you!
What?
Was it a nightmare?
Was I in your walls?
Was I stalking you?
What?
What was that noise?
I'm so scary, so every dream about me would be a nightmare instead, you know?
I get to have another first victory.
What do you mean?
Cubic, thank you for the very specific pink.
Thank you!
We will never forget about you, Lilac.
I'm having an identity crisis every day at this point.
I think I have identity crisis all the time now.
I don't know if you guys like me or not.
She was stuck in my bookshelf.
What do you mean I was stuck in your bookshelf?
I think I should...
Golly gosh!
Gosh!
I'm gonna die at this rate.
There we go.
Nevermind, I'm not gonna die.
Never die!
Do you actually think we don't like you?
I don't know.
I'm insecure.
I know what for.
Wait, can I Asakoko...
We hate to love you.
We love to hate you.
We'll always love Flintstones.
Flintstones, meet the Flintstones.
Nice attack style.
Oh my gosh, my pickup is at 400.
We're so close to getting to 500.
Oh wait, I don't think I will here though, right?
Because...
I don't think I will, because...
I'm not doing endless.
Grandad.
Welcome back, Mito!
I can never forget about you, for better or for worse.
Yeah, I'm haunting you.
I have to haunt you more.
Oh yeah, the nightly milk.
Let's see if we can re-roll for it.
Re-roll!
I'll do it next time.
We love you, maid channel.
Oh yeah, I forgot I can eliminate stuff.
Maybe it would help because I'm taking a lot of damage, but...
At the same time...
I don't know.
But plushie is new?
No, plushie is not new.
What can I do with the Asakoko?
Oh, I like it with the bomb.
Oh, elimination had a bug?
I know, right?
Before I streamed, there was another update.
I said it fixed some stuff, so...
Let's do...
Let's just do spider cooking.
Extra stenchy.
Extra stink.
The smell of a hag...
Permeates in all ways.
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, Sat.
Haunt me more!
Oh my gosh, couple, your profile picture is sad gengar.
Stinky stink stink stink stink.
We'll get it naturally, maybe.
Oh yeah, that's right, I have the dash.
Wait, I'm gonna try using it.
Oh, oh, oh, god.
I went right into them.
My friend has me saved in his phone as Ash's lost hot dog gacha.
What the hell, that's so mean!
So please let me win this time.
Oh, I actually don't know what you got.
Why can't I get the nightly milk?
Oh, you got the hot dog, let's go.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Once I'm done with this stage, I'll go get my perfume.
Matara's perfume.
For you guys.
I'm keeping, I'm just thinking about...
Smells now.
I've never, I've never, I'll be honest.
I've never been brave enough to get one of those, like...
This is the scent of an OL type things, you know?
I've never been brave enough to get one.
But maybe next time I go to Japan, I will go to M's and I'll buy some.
And then I can bring some and then I will review them on stream.
I wonder if it's a classy perfume.
I don't know.
My next merch?
But
don't you already smell like OL?
No, there's like several of them, right?
It'll be like...
This is the smell of...
Of...
I don't...
Scratch and sniff Ducky Makura.
Should I tell them to include a scratch and sniff with all Ducky Makura pre-orders now?
Minto in 4D.
Oh my gosh.
They used to do that with the...
On the TV shows and stuff.
But they always smelled terrible.
It would be like, scratch and sniff right now!
And it would smell like actual feet.
What do I have?
This is like the worst setup I've ever had.
Reroll, reroll.
You guys know how I did the HALU before?
I... So basically, I got to...
What is... There's an achievement, right?
For finishing with HALU level 5.
I did it up to level 4 and then like...
Like with like 10 seconds left, I went up to HALU 5.
And I got the achievement.
I think I did.
That's how I did it.
Sneaky.
Okay.
We'll do it.
Grab it.
More money, more money.
More money, more problems.
Because I'll be going back...
Into the casino.
No.
Give me nightly milk, please.
Oh my gosh, they're so tough.
I need more haste, honestly.
More money.
I love how HALU 5 is just please stop.
Okay, I'm gonna eliminate... Oh gosh.
Oh wait.
Oh, but this will...
Okay, let's just grab the elite lava bucket.
We'll collab these two.
They're all getting so close to me.
Why won't you guys die already?
Give me my boxes, please.
Oh.
Oh, I just got an onion.
Nice.
I think I should take this nurse's horn.
With the way I'm playing today.
I'm not paying attention at all.
Maybe I shouldn't have picked such a...
Focus... Needs my focus game...
For the first time I'm streaming since...
Money!
Give me the money.
Smell accurate minto ducky feet?
Tuna, you're a feet man.
Really?
Oh my god.
Go away from my place.
I'm trapped.
Oh, my box.
Okay, we'll take that.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to finish any of these, but...
No, my box!
No, my double box!
Stay away.
I gotta get over there, please.
Please.
I'm gonna die because you guys are on top of me.
Yippee!
I want to get 500.
Phantom Thief concert next month?
Can't wait.
Thank you!
Not the self-report.
Don't shame?
I'm not.
I'm just...
I'm just surprised.
I'm glad that we are...
Well, sometimes I think we're a little too comfortable.
I'm happy that you're comfortable enough with confiding in me...
how you feel about things.
You know?
We're a community...
of freaks.
I'm gonna drop it for now.
I need to heal first.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I'm in.
Nightly milk!
Come home, please.
Oh, please.
I'm just thirsty for some milk.
Some big tall glass of milk would be mighty fine right now.
Gosh, if it's of the night variety.
Oh, I'm so thirsty.
Please.
Won't any knights open their bosoms for a desperate little ghost?
I'm turning into a wisp.
I'm losing so much energy.
I'm so thirsty.
Dang it.
Imagine if people had feet like birds.
Would we wear shoes?
I don't think so.
I'm gonna re-roll.
Oh, come on.
I don't wanna die.
Please.
Oh, I got a koi fish.
So cute.
Oh, a carrot.
I got a carrot.
Let's go.
Oh, my god.
Hoshiyomi, please.
Guys, I don't think I'm getting this.
You are already dead.
True.
Isn't there a minotaur farm around here?
I don't wanna think about it.
I know I gotta get kind of close, but then they just pile on top of me.
It's so scary.
If my haste was higher, it'd be better, because then I'd be like...
Oh, my god.
I did not notice.
I did not notice the...
Oh, my god.
Oh, my gosh.
I was losing health.
I don't even know.
Yeah!
She likes Toho, so she probably...
What?
What are you saying about me?
Asking... Would asking for scent of armpit be too DJ?
I'm asking for me.
Oh,
my god.
I got stuck on something.
I don't know why.
The armpit did this.
So freaky, it ended the run.
Oh, man.
Anyway...
Oh, my god.
Not an easy game to play and retry.
I know, but that's all good.
That's why I played so much off-stream.
Kaichou time or peko time?
Eenie, meenie, miney, moe.
Catch a peko by his toe.
If he pekos, let him go.
My mama said to pick the very best one.
And you are it.
Peko!
Except it's Coco.
We'll do the same.
We'll do the same...
Same place.
So she's just got a little slash.
Mari's Toho album with Kool & Create was my...
Was the first VTuber merch I bought.
Her version of Help Me Eddy was so good.
Yeah.
I was thinking about her...
Her Toho album this past weekend, actually.
Super Teto time!
Even if I die, I always think of the money first.
Guys...
In games, I'm greedy, okay?
Actually, I'm also greedy.
You guys, I think I've realized this.
This... I think...
I think I... That's what I realized.
I think I'm...
Maybe too greedy.
But not just for money.
She finally realized.
What do you mean?
I think I'm just greedy.
I hate this feeling.
Thank you for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
By the way, happy Friday everybody.
Money for Metal Gear merch.
Stop!
I bought the cushions today.
You're greedy for our love and attention.
No, leave me!
Greed is sin, Minto.
I know.
I'm a sinner.
Grab it anyway.
Actually, it might actually be good for Coco.
Give me the box.
Special attack action can execute other attacks.
When the special gauge is at 50%.
Huh?
Wait.
What is that?
Wait, what is that?
No, no, no.
What is this?
What the...
Oh, it's a fan letter!
Oh my god!
I'll get the limiter and then we'll get the dragon.
I've never seen one.
Oh, I got some wood.
Greedy for our love, but we won't marry you.
That's fine.
We're homies.
It's fine.
Oh wait, if a target takes damage within the first 5 seconds after spawning...
They take 1.10 damage.
All Asakoko weapons have...
Life... Wait, there's more.
Life steal, 5%.
Asakoko's negative effects are negated.
So even the Asakoko medicine...
That I don't think I've ever used once.
Maybe...
Yay!
RGB!
Oh my gosh, it looks so pretty with her weapon.
Are you saying you wouldn't marry a bro?
If we had...
If we had to, maybe.
I don't know.
Stop asking me hard questions.
I'm gonna special!
That
was fun.
I marry and then I divorce later.
This is why you signed the prenup.
This is why...
The best homies marry their homies.
Oh I can... Targets may become marked.
Get marked!
I would marry you even if you were RGB.
Why do they have a tan?
Oh, it's from me.
Oh, no, strengthen.
There we go.
That's the meta.
I love RGB.
I'm glad I'm not a dog and I can see in color.
Yay!
For not being a... I got that dog in me though.
I'm not a dog, but I am a dog.
You know what I mean?
Super chat time!
I got that dog in me.
But I'm not a dog.
I'm just a... I'm a dog.
You know?
Sup dog.
Oh, wait.
Sup dog!
Wait.
What's dog?
What's up dog?
Wait.
No,
wait...
What is... Wait...
What's up dog... No, that's the same thing I've been saying.
I'm asking the question though.
Wait...
Do you know up dog?
No, what's up dog?
Yeah, what's up with you?
It's confusing.
You know what I was trying to ask though.
It means what is up... Yeah, but I'm asking... I was asking you...
You were supposed to... I'm supposed to say...
What is up dog?
And you're supposed to say...
What's up dog?
And then... Like, because you don't know...
And then I say...
Then I say...
Nothing, you...
You what?
Huh?
Wait...
That's not right, but that's literally what I just did.
I asked the question and you say what is it and then I answer.
You guys just don't understand the joke.
You guys are a little confused.
So... What's... What's... What's dog... Wait...
What's up dog is like a term that when you are asking someone...
It's like a casual way of asking someone how are they doing.
And so it's like a...
Then you ask them what that is and they say I don't know what that is and then you say...
Yeah, that... How are you doing?
But you're asking as a joke.
You don't really care about how they're doing.
What do you think?
Why?
Let me get my box.
I dropped the toilet.
Cool fact.
Anyway, have you heard of up dog?
Would you have a up dog or a matter baby?
I love the...
Let's take the EN's curse.
Oh my gosh.
I'm dropping everything.
I don't really understand this one, I think.
Wait, hold on.
My chat is stupid.
Hold on one second.
Not you guys.
You're not stupid.
YouTube chat froze so it's being stupid.
I didn't call you stupid, okay?
Uh-oh, YouTube froze.
One second.
I'm bringing you back.
Viewers are reacting to a streamer named Minto's joke about what's a matter baby.
Oh my god, there should be a Vtuber named matter baby.
It's just like... And then people are like, who's matter baby?
You're just like, what's a matter with you?
Why the...
Da...
Dash...
Oh, I don't know how to say that dog's name.
The dash...
Sit in the shade.
It was a hot dog.
Wiener dog.
What's up, baby?
Don't call me baby!
Zoomers have come up with the term...
Eyeladies.
Eyeladies?
Docsun.
Oh!
I don't get it.
Eyeladies.
If I say, what's eyeladies?
You say, what's a lady?
I am a lady.
Oh my gosh, too much katakana for me to read.
Thank you very much.
What's eyeladies with you?
Is this supposed to be a dumb joke?
Is that what the new...
What's it called?
Oh my gosh.
Next iPhone will be called the Eyeladies.
That's what the...
You know how they say by 2025 more people will be having sex with robots?
Eyeladies.
Would you say you smell of up dog?
No.
You're saying I smell...Oh no!
I forgot to get the Asa Coco!
Are you saying I smell like a dog?
Are you saying I smell like a...
Where is my...
Are you saying I smell like a dog?
Kinda messed up.
I hate playing Asa Coco, but I'm also kinda just bad.
But I'm also barely paying attention.
Hey, leave me alone!
Oh, my box.
Hold on, I gotta get my box.
Who's doing research on robot sex anyway?
Who is it?
I'm just gonna get out of here.
I'm gonna get out of here.
Oh my god, please.
Burger?
Any burgers?
Any hamburgers around?
Guys, I'm so sore from my trip.
I could barely move this morning.
I'm so sore.
I think we danced too much.
All the dancing.
I know.
Oh my gosh, but I think it's pretty committed to ectoplasm memory now though, so...
I think I'll be okay.
Flower!
Flower.
Oh my god, am I actually gonna die?
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
I can't die like this.
Flower.
Remember to dash.
Oh yeah, I keep forgetting that I even have this ability.
Wait, so if I dash...
Oh, wait, it only...
Okay, interesting.
It doesn't go the direction I'm facing.
I understand.
Anybody, any...
Any hamburgers?
If I had a daughter, she'd be named Shannon.
Okay, that's a pretty average name.
Why did you say that to me?
When people see her, they'll say...
Oh hey, it's Shannon again.
Oh, like shenanigan.
Oh, Shannon and all her shenanigans.
Die, die, die, die.
I think I gotta get out of here.
Oh, my health is all back to normal.
Yippee!
These are nuts.
None!
Still, don't talk like that.
You guys are teaching non-bad things.
I want non to only send me superchats about Ace Combat.
Don't teach him bad things!
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Rikyu, welcome.
Rikyu's bald and I can be too.
Welcome to membership.
We're not well, are we everybody?
Oh gosh, oh gosh!
Guys, I'm in trouble.
Guys, I'm in trouble for real.
Oh, oh god.
Guys, I'm in trouble.
Why am I so bad at this game?
I'm so bad at this game, everybody.
I think we're gonna die for real.
Oh my god.
Peko, peko!
Swap.
You are not locked in.
I really am not.
Sorry.
I really am not locked in today.
I just got...
I should have dashed.
It's OK.
We're getting a little sample of... I didn't even make it to 10 minutes.
We're getting a sample of everybody.
We're getting a sample.
OK, I wish I was... Can I change it from control?
She launches missiles?
Oh boy, oh boy.
OK.
I'll save those for later.
Crap.
You can remind it?
OK, I will.
Every 15 seconds, roll a... Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
How much did I get?
I'm not good with such aiming.
Pyromaniac.
Oh yeah.
More explosion.
Peko, peko, peko.
I'm starting to think that you're cute.
That is a side effect of the Minto virus.
Nice combat tastes nice.
How much
money can I make?
Money!
Minto cute.
Oh my God.
I didn't even notice.
Increase.
Let me get to my stuff.
All weapons have a 10% chance to gain 20% size.
Gain stacks of luck that is equal to half of... Oh no.
Pekora is all about luck, you guys.
This is my...
I'll never make it.
If Pekora is all about luck, I'll never make it.
I'll never make it out alive.
Minto virus.
Yeah, you're already infected.
You're already infected.
It's okay.
There is no cure.
But it is fun.
Keep getting the rocket launcher.
Nice!
We keep winning lots of money.
Can you... I imagine you can lose, right?
Like you can't lose.
It'd be ridiculous otherwise.
My money!
I need the limiter, please.
Am I dying?
No!
What's the survival rate?
Nice!
Don't want no stinking cure.
You guys are so funny.
Launch.
Oops.
Oh wait.
We'll just hold on to it for now.
We won't use it.
I don't like that one.
It's good for only like if you're doing that one challenge where you don't...
Level up your main weapon, right?
0%.
Thought about playing Resident Evil series.
Maybe.
I'm not opposed.
Maybe like the remakes of some of the games which...
Which might make some people be like...
Oh, you're only gonna play the remake?
But...
I've played old Resident Evil and I'm not...
So good at it.
I didn't beat it.
I mean I was like, you know, really young when I played it, but...
Still no DMC.
What are you talking about?
I just got back.
Oh, I didn't make any more money.
Of course there will be more DMC.
Let's see...
This does...
Just let me get back into it, you know?
Yay!
Use special to kill singular enemy.
Oh yeah, yeah.
What is Peko's special actually?
Let's see!
Oh, I still have to move around?
Okay.
Jackpot!
Hot dog indeed.
My eyes.
Month 7 of Minto virus.
Thank you.
A cure has been found, but Wisps refuse to take it.
Sighting that Minto is their Kamiyoshi and don't need a cure.
Good.
I just keep haunting you.
That's really it.
The more I haunt...
Maybe it's like a Stockholm syndrome.
Perhaps.
Get in line, Ari bro.
We Yakuza bro as first.
Oh, what was it?
Quite recently, they had like a sale...
Of all the Yakuza games and I bought them all, so...
I'm ready for...
After DMC...
I'm ready to go...
Well, I don't know if I'm gonna do Ace Combat first or...
Yakuza first.
They're both long, so...
But I do have all of them.
I'm ready.
I'll take that.
I need more healing things, cause I'm stupid.
What the?
That box didn't have anything in it.
Alright, let's go for more money!
Yeah!
Get in line, bozos.
Minto promised she'd start...
She gets back...
I did say that, didn't I?
There's so many things to do!
What was I thinking of with the axe?
OK, sorry guys.
We're gonna eliminate them.
OK.
So many games.
So many games and I would say so little time, but actually...
There's a lot of time.
You know?
There's a lot of time, so...
It's all good.
Or you can play Yakuza first.
I don't mind.
Why do you think it's only for you, huh?
I also wanna play.
Huh?
Infinite time.
Yeah.
Lots of time.
So don't worry, guys.
You're like, she'll never get around to it.
There's time.
It's all good.
It's all OK.
I like just the random bouts of money that just spring...
Am I never gonna get another staff?
What is this?
I try to be nice to you.
Even 9 is being tsundere to me.
What is this?
I played Ace Combat 7 this year and it was amazing, isn't it?
So...
So good.
Glad to hear you had a good trip, Minto.
Looking forward to having streams to relax during the night again.
Yeah.
I did have a good trip.
It was fun.
It was a...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'll do Spider-Quick again.
My luck, though, is just so bad the whole trip.
I forgot a bunch of stuff.
I had a moment where, like...
Where...
I bring... I have daily contacts, right?
And I opened up one of my contacts and it was already dried out.
Luckily, I always bring, like, an extra day's worth.
And at first I thought I didn't have enough, but I actually did have enough, so...
It was okay, but...
You should play more streams...
Or more games off-stream.
Wait.
Why did that bother?
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, but I was just so annoyed because now my eyes are two different prescriptions, right?
So now I have...
I have one extra.
So annoying.
And then...
While everyone is recommending games, if my monkey's paw wish comes true and they re-release Transformers War for Cybertron on Steam...
You should definitely play the co-op campaign with Doki.
I don't think I have this one.
There was one...
There was...
One...
Game I got...
That was a Transformers game.
That...
I think was only for Xbox.
I'll have to check it later.
That's gonna bother me.
Devastation?
It might have been.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, oh, oh, box!
Where did this box come from?
Yay, money!
Take.
It's free.
Am I ever gonna get another sticker ever again?
Or another stamp?
Maybe not.
Take.
Yippee!
Nice.
Spudder cookie.
I like Pekora.
Yeah.
I like playing as her.
Ok, that one's max.
Nice.
Ok, there we go.
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
Upgrade?
Free upgrade, let's go.
Aw, man.
What did I get as my item?
I don't remember.
No one has them.
My memory is Hasbro literally lost the game file.
So unless you bought it back in the day, it's lost to time.
Maybe then I don't have it.
I don't know which one I have.
I'm gonna check later.
Dash?
I don't...
Oh, I do have dash.
Just kidding.
I thought it was down here in the bottom left.
Ok, I did get dash.
Yeah!
Is Pekora...
Is she...
Lacking in...
In...
Uh...
Does she have...
Yes?
Really?
She always gives a big boob energy.
She's in the middle.
Cutting board is good for her.
I wish I had dash.
I wish I...
I wish I had... Ok, we'll get the bouncy ball then.
I wish I had dashed earlier.
I
think I already have the achievement for...
For...
For getting rid of one, by the way, in case you're wondering.
Super headphones.
I'll take it.
Uh...
I was able to finish Ace Combat 5.
On the time of the 20th anniversary.
Oh, nice!
I feel like Pekora is...
Fun for money, but not great for money.
Unless maybe it's good...
If you have...
Oh, I wanted to pee a little bit.
It's good if you have... What's it called?
Oh my god.
I can finally get the other staff.
What was I saying?
Oh, good if you have greed is what I was about to say.
Upgrade!
Bouncy ball.
Biyobo.
Nice.
Super chat... Oh yeah, or super chatto, right?
Unless that doesn't affect her...
Thing, I'm not sure.
Goodness.
I got another one.
What's this one?
Yeah.
That would have been so good for the...
Wait, Marine was not crit, was it?
It was pick up.
Just kidding.
Oh, super chatto time does help her.
Minto personifies greed.
Oh, not windows.
My tab just crashed.
Am I still live?
Viewers are reacting to Minto holo cure gameplay discussing various aspects of the gameplay.
I am a kicker.
I'm not live.
In fact, I'm quite dead.
I'm quite dead actually.
Yeah, you thought.
I used it, I used it.
We are doing game suggestions.
No!
I have so many games that I need to get through.
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness, oh my goodness.
I saw the TMNT...
TMNT...
Shredder's Revenge.
Six player online?
No way.
Sorry, I'm like kind of paying attention.
Oh, nice!
We are doing so much better with Peckle.
Study glasses.
Isn't this better to get like towards the beginning?
Hey, first super chat here.
I have to correct the other guy.
You didn't super chat just to correct somebody.
You didn't super chat just to... Actually...
Hasbro did not lose the transformer files.
Activision just doesn't have the license right now.
I would cite my source, but I have no room.
Thank you, Nicholas.
There you go.
The source is the super chat... The source is he has no room.
Why didn't you just put source semicolon source name?
Ace Combat is... If you're really good, you can speedrun.
I'm gonna be so bad when I... You know what?
I'll just take it.
It's free.
I'm gonna be so bad when I get back to playing it again since I haven't played it in so long.
I'm gonna stall all the time.
No!
Let's do a bouncy ball.
We'll get a cutting board eventually, probably.
Oh my gosh, we're blowing up everything.
Let's go.
Nice.
Weep,
weep, weep, weep.
Guys, I'm getting so sleepy.
Re-roll.
Bouncy ball.
I wanna play some Blackjack some more.
I wanna play all the Blackjack.
Peter, thanks for 7 months.
Thank you.
Watch other people play.
Ace Combat girl channel.
A female is playing Ace Combat.
Oh my god.
A girl is playing Ace Combat.
This guy is no no gender.
What is this?
Oh, I guess it works.
Wait, is my green maxed out?
Nope, nevermind.
I'm greedy.
I'm greedy!
Oh no.
I guess we'll do the steady glasses.
Do you think we'll beat this one finally, you guys?
I'm not locked in.
Oh wait, I forgot.
I can use my special and get more money.
Or not!
What?
Are you kidding me?
You can even lose that?
I hate this.
I'm never playing Pakora again.
What are you talking about?
Still does damage though.
I guess that's good.
I guess.
Oh, steady glasses.
Apply.
Girls don't play video games, you guys.
Girls paint their nails and are stupid.
Girls don't play video games.
They paint their nails, talk about tiny dresses and be stupid.
Everybody knows this.
Stopping by to check in.
By the way, I check in every once in a while.
Because I'm not allowed to watch Vtubers.
Tell girls to stop coming for my hobbies.
What's your hobby, huh?
Maybe your hobby is really fun.
What the?
New stamp.
Why?
Rock hard.
While not moving, increase the damage of this weapon by 20% and reduce the time between all weapons by 30%.
OK, I have to not move.
OK, we'll get the box and then we'll move.
Who's holding you against your will?
Why can't you watch Vtubers?
Unless you're just like, it's too cringe for me to handle.
I can't handle the second hand cringe.
It's too cringe.
Too cringe.
You know what?
Screw it.
It's free.
OK, good.
We lived.
You get used to it pretty quick.
My hobby is experiencing second hand cringe.
You're so brave.
If you're looking for cringe, you've come to the right place.
I'm the cringe queen.
The queen of cringe.
Officially inviting all girls to come to my hobbies.
Yeah.
Tiara is single and ready to mingle in hobbies.
Does it look like the tongue ever slightly looks like Pantsu?
Wait, it looks more like a Pantsu.
No, no, no.
It does not.
Time to cut!
We're gonna live.
Somehow I had invincibility or something.
Somehow I'm so good at this game.
It doesn't look like... The old one looked like panties.
I'll agree with you there.
But the new one doesn't look like panties at all.
I'm collecting my...
There we go.
Nice.
Time to see a fanny pack.
You guys have such mighty imaginations.
I love that for you.
You guys have such brilliant imaginations.
I bet growing up in class you got told you were a gifted child, huh?
You're the queen of Akihabara.
That title is definitely not for me.
That title is for the one and only Momoi Haruko.
Wait, what goes over the glow stick?
Is it the fan beam?
I don't think we'll get to... Super chat time!
I'm guessing you relate.
How else would I know if I didn't relate?
My attempts to become rich through gambling have not paid off.
But I did come up with a fun idea while drinking moonshine.
I'm going to infuse my honey with mint when I get home.
What is moonshine?
I have a friend that she really loves it.
But I don't even know what it is.
Homemade alcohol.
Alcohol made from corn.
Is it like a...
I've only ever heard... It sounds like a... What's it called?
How do I say?
Like a southern thing.
Moonshine.
It really burns?
My friend's crazy.
Yeah, she's always just like, I gotta go get my moonshine.
It's like 90... 90% alcohol?
My friend's getting...
She's... How?
How?
I don't think I've ever seen her drunk before though.
Maybe I should use my special.
Oh, nevermind.
I did it!
She's probably joking.
No!
She says how much she likes it.
All the time.
Flavor of steel.
Must be.
Welcome to my... Thank you!
Oh my gosh guys, we might actually live through this.
We might live!
Uh oh.
The little guys are coming in.
8-chan inbound.
Peckle power?
Nah, I think we got this for real.
What's this?
Uh oh.
Attack size?
Let's just do my attack finally.
I wish though I could complete the fan beam.
I have this turkey up here.
I've just left it out.
Whatever.
I like Pekoras.
But...
I'm also scared of Gacha.
Alright.
And...
It's thawing.
True.
Oh my god, we just made so much money.
Jackpot baby.
I wish I could get more.
What's this one again?
Oh yeah.
Money.
That's what it is.
Boom!
Double chunk chocolate chunks.
I've come around so much on the Costco guys that...
It's just, it's so cringe it's funny to me at this point.
You know what I mean?
I hate this one.
Boom!
Double chunk chunk chocolate cookie.
But it's like, not funny...
Like I don't watch them, I just, I think it's funny to quote it.
You know what I mean?
Oh nice, nice, nice.
We might actually get the thing.
Oh my god.
Oh my good.
There we go.
Where's my gold?
We're mental guys.
I'll take it.
Where's my gold anvil?
Nice.
What if I gotcha right here?
In the butt.
Wow!
My eyes are not for the Toho's right now.
Oh, I thought she died.
Thought we were close.
During Minecraft hardcore collab, you used both Mog and Cap.
Completely unironically.
What happened to you?
Blame Doki for everything.
I legitimately become dumb around her, so...
Honestly, it's not my fault.
You can blame Doki for everything.
Also, shut the hell up Nani.
I don't wanna hear anything.
I don't wanna hear anything from you.
Okay?
Yay!
We did it!
Blame accepted.
I will thank her.
You're both extra cute like this.
Justice for Nani.
Would Big Boss use that language?
Only language that Big Boss would use, right?
Only the language of the Big Boss.
Oh my god.
If I make them not hungry...
Look, they come to the fence begging for food.
You want some food?
Only Bloodloss gets food.
He's gonna become my horse.
Okay, come on.
Come on, Bloodloss.
We're sending you to the...
To the rink.
Come on.
Come on, Bloodloss.
There was another one here too, right?
It was like a...
Actually, this one.
Racing.
I can train him.
Alright, Bloodloss, train.
Level point eleven.
Oh, I see.
That's why I couldn't tell that I needed to train.
Oh, it's expensive.
Oh no.
It's worth it.
He's training.
Yeah!
Bloodloss.
Alright, Bloodloss, go into the race.
Hot dog.
Course one.
There's a fee to join.
Alright, Bloodloss.
Why you have only... Wait.
Oh, wait.
Maybe he doesn't have the best stats.
You know what?
Whatever.
Here we go.
Go!
Oh my god.
I'm scared for you.
Why are you lagging behind a little bit?
Oh my god.
No, he's good.
He's good.
Go, Bloodloss!
Go!
Oh my god.
Bloodloss!
Redemption.
I believe in you, Bloodloss.
Holy moly.
Oh my god.
Bloodloss!
Oh...
Rinto!
You and Doki are my kami-yoshi.
I wanted a happy birthday from both of you during the off-colab.
I thought I could wait until next month.
I forgot my birthday is not the 18th next month.
What do you mean you forgot?
Cypher!
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday, Cypher!
Nobody tell Tear, by the way.
Nobody tell Tear.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Cypher!
What was it?
I don't remember why we were talking about you, Doki and I.
But she mentioned that she met you at a meet-and-greet.
And she was like, you're that, Cypher?
Funny.
Bloodloss, maybe we need to train him some more.
Train!
Okay, I'm spending big bucks on you, Bloodloss.
You're gonna be so good, okay?
I don't need... Actually, train a little bit more.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, big bucks.
Big bucks.
Alright.
Go into racing!
It's the Beginner's Cup.
How is it so difficult?
Go, Bloodloss!
Go!
Oh, and he's fast.
Look at him go!
Oh my god!
Yes!
Bloodloss!
Oh my gosh!
Win a worker race!
Let's go!
Easy win.
Entry fee.
What?
There's obstacles in other ones?
Oh, there's sand.
And water and wind.
Oh no, Anya just died in the casino.
Pato just died in the casino.
Redemption!
Mirror, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
Let's see.
Champion's Cup.
He's not ready for these leagues, not yet.
In fact, I'm gonna do another race.
Make back my money.
Come on!
Go!
Bloodloss!
You're the fastest!
You're the greatest!
I love watching the deadbeat just drop to the ground.
Oh my gosh!
The Takodachi is so small!
Win!
I can make so much money from this probably.
Actually, I only make 100 every time.
Alright.
Is he good enough?
I'll try a second.
He's still a little fast.
Go Bloodloss!
Go!
Bloodloss!
Oh my God!
It's tight!
Yeah!
You can charge the running.
Wait, what do you mean?
You can use...
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
You can press space for what?
You can shift for boost and space to recover stamina.
You can?
Hey!
Welcome to Wacker Race!
You can enter leagues of different races with one of your...
...wackers.
You can win a race and pay an entry fee up front.
Then cheer your worker and get first place or win a prize.
It's that simple.
Your worker will run or swim or that takes energy.
You can cheer your worker with space.
They'll rest to recover energy.
Or if they have enough energy, you can press shift and they'll sprint.
But that takes a lot of energy.
Whatever it takes to win first place.
If your worker is no good, you can train them to increase their stats.
Each worker can train...
Wait, each worker can training points.
Based on their current level.
Raise your worker's level to get more points.
Then you can decide how to...
I see.
But it also costs money to train them.
Craziness.
Wait, now I want to see.
Blood loss, win this time.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I see, I see.
Look, he is still faster.
Uh-oh, wait.
That might have been about it.
Rest, rest, rest.
Guys,
I did so much better without cheering on my guy.
This is why you don't backseat.
Yeah, maybe he was okay on his own.
He had blood loss.
No, the blood loss is others.
They made a sport just like this that you can bet on.
It's called horse racing.
And it's based on Uma Musume.
Oh, wow.
Horse racing, yes.
Uma Musume goes back thousands of years.
Tell my kids this is Uma Musume.
What about... I didn't do the roulette either.
Oh my gosh, there is so much to do.
Place your chips in any color slot.
You don't get so many though.
Oh, stop.
I won 20.
This one is boring.
Oh, it feels so good.
We didn't do this one either though.
The higher, lower.
Let's bet a thousand.
Confirm bet.
Lower?
Next round.
Lower.
Higher.
Next round.
Oh my god, I'm hitting big numbers, big numbers, big numbers.
At the casino, baby.
When do we get Minto and Vegas Arc?
I'm here.
I'm in Vegas.
No math?
I tried the math earlier.
Higher.
I'm gonna do normal.
Okay.
42.
2.
7 times 4.
I don't know 7 times 4.
Wait, 28?
14, 21, 28.
Please, I'm scared.
Stop moving.
There's not a time limit, right?
So it's nice at least.
Wait, 6.
Carry the 1.
76.
Move, please.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, I almost shot it.
Nice.
120?
4, 30, 34.
I'm over here.
Excuse me, excuse me, excuse me.
Why does this feel like a goddamn Mario Party minigame?
Oh shoot.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Nice, okay.
Daska!
Miss you too.
Send me more pictures of your feet.
I mean your dog.
Please ban Orca pretty please.
Okay.
Orca, come here.
Come here.
Mr. Broken Bon, thank you for the Orca Super, thank you.
Oh, wait.
4 times 18.
18, 18, plus 18.
6.
36, no.
Wait, 36.
Wait.
Wait, oh wait.
8 plus 8 is... wait.
But then it's 18 times 3.
Because we're dividing it by 4.
Wait, 18 times 4 divided by 4.
Isn't that just 18?
I didn't read the whole thing you guys, okay?
Okay, I only read the first part.
Come here.
This guy is trying to sabotage me.
Oops, I wasn't paying attention.
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
24, 24.
36.
7, 8, 9, 77.
Okay, 2 times...
2 times...
24, 24.
9!
Yeah!
Come here, come here, come here.
How hard do these math problems get?
Why are they trying to make us smarter?
48 divided by 8?
48?
Is it 6 or 4?
It's basic math, Minto.
I didn't go to math class!
6?
It's 6?
I missed all of my elementary math classes.
Ah...
How?
Basically...
I had to go to a special program at my school.
But the special program always took place during the...
During the...
Math class.
It was for...
It was for students with troubled homes, okay?
That's why I'm bad at math!
Oh gosh...
34 divided by 2.
17?
Right?
Come on!
Oh
no!
Wait!
48, right?
That's the highest number here.
It's gotta be.
5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40...
And I was 5.
Oh, there it is in the corner.
Nice.
Yay!
That's so sad.
Can we get 20 gifted?
No!
Yippee!
Minto is taking HoloCure for math credits.
I had the same thing in school.
That's why I'm bad at math.
It was yours during math class too!
Perfect!
Oh my gosh, perfect.
Stop!
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Yay!
We did math.
I did the normal math, you guys.
How far does this get?
So endless... Oh, it's just infinity questions.
But challenge is probably even harder questions, right?
Is there things like squared and...
What if there's Pythagorean theorems in there?
You want to challenge yourself?
But the payout...
I've sung the alphabet and forgot what comes next.
If you say that you have to eat a dog, they get elemental pee.
The scaling of endless is just too much.
There's time limit in endless.
No!
Hell no.
So sad.
Can we get a...
Thank you for the bed!
Meow!
Meow, thank you!
Hello, hello.
Welcome back!
I forgot to say welcome back to everybody at the beginning of the stream.
Because I was so mad about everything.
About my feelings.
Thank you for the 20!
Thank you for the 5!
I started the Tower of Suffering when you started the stream.
I'm stuck at 67%.
So you really have been going at it for 3 hours.
Let's go try it too.
Oops, I think I just saw Pekora cry and leave.
Sometimes the music is a little too much for me.
It's nice to just have a little break.
Thank you for the 20!
Thank you for the 5!
Thank you guys.
The casino music.
Yeah!
I should thank you for the 5, captain.
It took me 7 and a half hours to beat the tower.
Thank you for the 20!
7 and a half hours?
Has the game even been out that long?
Oh, I guess so.
I got to 4%.
I think?
I'm at 1%.
Oh my goodness.
Holy cow, I'm already at 2%.
Back to 2%.
Can never escape.
3%.
Oh, back to 2%.
Shady, thank you for the 50!
I've never been good at...
So did Callie beat this then?
I've never been good at Jump King.
4%.
I can see the 4% happening.
See you guys.
4%.
Nice.
It's so hard.
Yeah, but there is a hot babe.
And this one says there is a cute girl.
Who is it?
Who is the cute girl?
I wonder.
It's a mirror, so I was right, huh?
Oh!
I don't like watching my Oshie fall to her face.
You know, it's so sad.
Watching my Oshie fall flat on her face.
So sad.
The cute girl is at the bottom right of the screen.
Nice.
Not nice.
My right.
Bottom left even better.
Balthazar, thanks for the gifted.
Thank you!
They meant the bottom of the screen.
Oh my gosh, I'm so glad I have my pants on today.
Holy cow, that would have been bad.
Centered as all things should be.
Do you get a buff if you play as Callie in this?
I wonder.
Oops.
Why didn't it...
Nice.
Now I can't see the rest of the level.
Cute girl keeps moving around the screen edges.
It's you guys.
You guys are the cute girl.
Chat's the cute girl.
Oh!
Oops.
I wish I was a cute girl.
Don't we all wish we were cute girls?
Come on.
There would be world peace.
If so...
Oh my gosh.
I did it before.
I don't remember how I did it.
Go back this way.
That's why we need more Moe everybody.
Moe is justice.
And Moe will bring world peace.
Moe.
Moe will make every heart tender and lovely.
I am the bringer of Moe.
I appreciate the double song from the other day.
But can I get a happy birthday song from Mature Minto since today is my actual birthday.
Mature Minto.
Like a happy birthday Mr. President kind of mature.
Like a...
I swallowed my spit rock.
Okay.
Mature Minto.
Someone said am I even capable of being mature.
I am mature.
I'm mature.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
I haven't done it in so long.
It's so weird.
Okay.
This is a happy birthday for S810 Ritual on your birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday...
Mr. President of S810 Ritual.
Happy birthday to you.
Thanks for the aqua soup.
Mr. President.
George Sears.
Ara ara voice returns.
Ara ara.
My voice is always suitable for the ara ara.
What are you talking about everybody?
What if I bounce?
Bounce.
Nice!
Ara ara.
Are you cute because you are Minto or are you Minto because you are cute?
I'm going back in the middle.
I think it brought me good luck.
See?
How do I make this?
Maybe I stand here.
Maybe this is a clue.
Right here is a hint.
Can you do a frog burp?
Ara ara.
I can feel my blood pressure rising as I play this jump game.
Yeah.
I know.
Me too.
I have no blood.
Ectoplasm.
My ectoplasm is rising.
That was perfect.
And so will this jump!
Ara ara.
On the wall.
Who is the froggiest of them all?
It's me.
I'm not a real frog even though there is a froggy wawa right here.
I'm not a froggy.
Froggy time.
I'm jumping through the jump key.
It's just like a frog would.
Where is a froggy wawa outfit for this level?
Oh my god.
I can't get it.
D'oh.
What does Frogbert think of the femnani sensation?
Why couldn't you do it to Frogbert?
I think it would've been really sexy if it were me instead.
I'm just saying.
I mean, you can't even sex me up anymore than I already am though.
No!
That was
disgusting, wasn't it?
Frogbert is the sex symbol.
Absolutely.
No!
My god!
I don't know my own strength.
Any chance of...
Hey, you're doing alright, Ojisanma?
Voice pack for us old folks.
I'm doing okay, but honestly life just isn't that nice to us sometimes.
Thank you for the Haka Super!
Oh, I do want to do some voice packs.
What would you want for me to say?
Some motivating things for Goshijin-sama, Ojisanma?
It's hard for me to motivate though.
I mean, I'm just a ghost.
How do I motivate?
When I have no life, how do I motivate you for your life?
You know what I mean?
Oops.
How do I motivate you if I have no life?
I only have afterlife.
Solid Snake's speech at the end of MGS2.
That was so good.
My car wouldn't let me charge for the last six attempts.
No!
Please stop!
I think your bank is trying to tell you something.
Lure us to your maid cafe and then take our souls.
We're suckers for positive affirmations, huh?
Positive affirmations.
I think the most telling sign of you doing well is if a ghost tells you you're doing well.
Because, you know, I could just be like, you know, I'm dead.
I...
You could just be dead, but I'm a ghost and I'm telling you that you're doing a good job, you know?
Ghosts are the most unbiased creatures.
I wouldn't say that.
Tell us you'll fill our dark soul with light.
I...
I think...
This world and...
The afterlife...
The living life and the afterlife are both very big.
They're basically... They're almost probably the same.
And still...
In this hustle and bustle world...
You were able to find our little community and I think that's honestly something so special.
You know, I think that...
Taking time for yourself is...
And being able to just hang out with us and relax and everything is...
You know, a really good time.
It's good self-care for you and...
I think that if things do get too tough...
If things are also hard, you can always at least count on, you know...
The community being here for you and me being here for you.
And there's always gonna be a MintoStream to help you feel better.
You know, I think...
I think every day how...
I guess how grateful I am that, you know, there's so many VTubers you could watch and you're here watching me.
And...
How...
Out of all the billions and billions and billions of people in the world...
Or ghosts in the afterworld...
How we all were able to kind of find each other.
And so if you're ever just like, I'm feeling kind of lonely, like...
Honestly, it's almost like short of a miracle that we were all able to find each other.
So...
It's pretty fun.
So hopefully even when you're just like...
The tough times, just remember...
Tough time never last.
Only tough people last.
Wait,
can I show you guys those?
Hold on, I think I know where they're at.
I think I know where I saved them.
What?
Oh, my bad.
One second.
Under here.
What?
Where did I save this?
Motivational misspeech.
Thank you for the Akasupodoes.
Thank you, thank you.
Where do I have it saved?
I found it literally just the other day.
Where did I keep it?
Maybe here?
No.
Here?
I just found it like the other day.
I found it!
OK, you guys, these are my motivational quotes.
Is this me?
Hold on.
I have to listen real quick.
Oh, I think this is all of them.
OK, OK, we're going to watch these together.
We're going to watch these together.
Hold on, I'm going to put it on, but I'm going to pause it.
Pause, pause, pause.
I want to hear it too.
OK, hold on.
Hold on.
OK.
Here we go.
These are the motivational quotes to really learn and live by.
I'm dead, but I can still live by them too.
OK, here we go.
Here we go.
Let me start it over.
Tough times never last.
Only tough people last.
Life is a very difficult exam.
Many people are failing because they want to copy from others.
They want to copy from others.
Everyone has a different question paper.
Only the tallest tree has an experience of the roughest winds.
But the eagle flies higher above the clouds.
You guys feel so motivated.
No.
I love that video.
Truly a god amongst men.
Thank you Minto, just what I needed.
What is this frog?
What do you mean frog?
A little...
Only the eagle flies higher...
Wait, what is this one?
I think this one we already did.
Or is this a different one?
No, no, no.
There is more.
I have another video.
Pause, pause, pause.
I have another one.
Play.
Never ever carry your mistakes or your past with you.
Place them under your feet.
So that you can use them as a stepping stone to rise above.
So good, so good, so good.
With that guys...
I think I'm good too.
I think I might...
Head out now.
I really needed this, thank you Minto.
You're welcome.
Alan Wake, I want to play Alan Wake.
I want to play...
Make Frogbert versions.
Oh, I should.
Maybe I can when I finally have the 3D.
I can make some real 3D versions.
Just keep calm and...
Can I marry my love maid, Lilac?
Lilac doesn't believe in marriage.
Sorry.
Full blown Minto version of this.
The first voice back.
After being a lurker since 1.0.
What?
Ashes, you've been around for that long?
My god.
Seriously?
Finally coming out of my shell and meeting Wisps was the best thing I've ever done.
I've been able to form amazing friendships.
Thanks to your community.
Thank you for everything.
True OG.
What?
I had no idea.
Ashes was a lurker this whole time.
From 1.0.
Thanks for sticking around.
I've been here forever, bro.
What?
That's crazy.
Some of us have been here a long time, Minto.
I recognize some of your names.
Craziness.
Absolute craziness.
Well, thank you guys for streaming today.
And Holocure.
And Blackjack.
Blackjack, Blackjack, Blackjack, Blackjack, Blackjack, Blackjack, Blackjack.
I want to find...
Can we...
Online Blackjack for everybody to play together.
I'll try and find it.
Maybe I'll marry a Minto Daki someday.
A Daki?
Have you guys seen those Daki Makuras?
I saw them.
I saw them somewhat recently.
Those Daki Makuras that have like the...
They're like Oppai Mousepads, but Daki Makura.
And they have the boobs sewed on them.
That's kind of crazy.
That's crazy.
Have you guys seen those?
They're pretty powerful.
I want a Minto Daki Makura.
It'll come out...
Soon.
TM.
As long... As well as...
As well as...
Well, the Daki Makura are pre-order.
The...
Plushies will be...
Are ready to order.
And...
The Legos are ready to order.
Maybe some other stuff.
I can... Wait, I have the Daki Makura.
Somewhere.
Wait, I thought I had it in this folder.
Do I not?
Sorry, I'm so sleepy now.
Oh my gosh, it's almost 11 PM.
Wow, for me at least.
Mint Daki is going to be flat.
No, this is Isekai Minto.
It's Isekai Minto, so...
It's not...
Where did I save it?
I can't even show my own merch.
Wait, I know I sent it to this person.
Look at this.
These are the...
The Legos.
Wait, how do I turn the picture?
Rotate, rotate, rotate.
Okay, save.
Wait, it didn't save.
Rotate, rotate, rotate.
Save.
It didn't save.
Okay, I'll just show you guys.
Why isn't it working?
Guys, I think my computer is frozen.
I can't do anything in my downloads folder.
And I can't drag...
OBS is frozen!
Oh no!
Guys, I think OBS is frozen.
OBS is not responding.
Guys, I think this is a good time to end the stream.
Wait, let me test something.
I'm gonna go to the outro.
Maybe it'll work.
I can press the button.
Thank you guys for today's stream.
I really appreciate it.
I'll stream tomorrow.
Sometime.
And then I'll have an actual schedule for next week.
Thank you guys for the stream.
And...
Take care of yourselves.
Yeah.
Keep being freaks.
Hopefully this works.
I'm gonna press the button and see if it transitions.
Did it work?
No?
OBS is not responding.
I might just have to end the stream.
With no ending.
Uh oh.
YouTube is frozen.
How
do I end the stream?
Wait, you guys...
Let me restart YouTube.
OBS hates us.
Should I do karaoke now?
If I close the game.
It shows up that I closed it.
Okay, let's do karaoke.
Until everything works again.
What should I sing?
Alt F4?
No, but then...
I need to go to my ending screen.
What should I sing?
EN or JP?
EN.
YouTube is completely frozen for me.
What is happening?
I think my computer might be falling apart.
It's falling apart.
Did you guys see that new...
V Shoujo JP girls?
They're so cute.
Sorry, I just saw that there was a trailer for them on...
My For You page.
Karaoke.
I like the girl with the hammer.
What's her name?
Peke?
Peke is Peek.
She's so cute.
Hold on.
You know what?
Maybe there will be no ending.
Okay, I'll do one song.
I'll do one song.
Great Balls of Fire.
I don't know how it goes.
Will this work?
I've changed my mind.
This love is fine.
Goodness gracious.
Great Balls of Fire.
Kiss me baby.
Feels good.
Help me baby.
I don't know this song at all.
I want to love you like a lover should.
You're fine.
So kind.
Got to tell this world that you're mine, mine, mine, mine.
I chew my nails and then I twiddle my thumbs.
I'm real nervous, but it sure is fun.
Come on baby.
You drive me crazy.
Goodness gracious.
Great Balls of Fire.
Health is art.
Thanks for the gift.
Kiss me baby.
Feels good.
Hold me baby.
How does this part go?
I can't.
Hold on.
Kiss me baby.
Feels good.
Hold me baby.
I want to love you like a lover should.
You're fine.
So kind.
Got to tell this world that you're mine, mine, mine, mine.
I chew my nails and then I twiddle my thumbs.
I'm real nervous, but it sure is fun.
Come on baby.
You drive me crazy.
Goodness gracious.
Great Balls of Fire.
Is OBS better now?
No.
Wait, but your super...or your donuts are coming through.
Pirate, I see.
I'll repost or post my merch on Twitter whenever it comes out.
Thank you for the donation.
You're still young.
You keep calling yourself Ojiisan, but I think you're still young.
Don't worry.
I think you're okay.
What's another song I can sing?
Mint tried to leak the merch.
I'm Ojiisan too.
Me too.
We're all Ojiisans here.
Link to merch please.
There is no link because it's not out yet.
I'm sorry.
Japanese Goblin.
No, I'm a reincarnated Japanese princess.
Except I'm dead, so that doesn't make much sense.
Every time we touch.
Cause every time we touch, I get this feeling.
Oh, the MGS Con Kickstarter.
Yes, thank you.
I am a stretch goal in the MGS Con Kickstarter.
They're trying to have the convention next year, I believe in August.
And if we reach the Kickstarter goal, I will be one of the hosts for the convention.
Which is kind of cool, I think.
And...
Clans of Liberty.
No, no, no.
This is...
I actually don't know what this year is called.
It's based on MGS3.
Oh my gosh, and I'm even wearing my Metal Gear Solid Delta.
My loungewear right now.
That I got from GU.
But I would be alongside Vanessa Marshall.
And she is the voice of Olga in MGS2.
And also Strangelove in Peace Walker.
And MGSV, I suppose.
Con Eater, is that what it's called?
Yeah, yeah.
Strangelove, I know.
So crazy.
That little old me.
Little old me.
Did you hear about Real Eva's BA?
I did!
But it was like an open secret.
Everybody knew.
Wait, I can sing that!
It's a Metal Gear song.
Part of your world.
This is technically Metal Gear adjacent now.
If it'll play.
I don't know how loud it is.
Look at this stuff.
Isn't it neat?
Wouldn't you think my collection's complete?
Wouldn't you think I'm the girl?
The girl who has everything.
I know it's a lot of reverb.
Why is it so high?
How many wonders can one cavern hold?
Looking around here you'd think.
Sure.
She's got everything.
I've got gadgets and gizmos aplenty.
My OBS is frozen.
I can't end stream.
So...oh wait.
My OBS is frozen so I can't end stream and I do karaoke.
Gonna be where the people are.
I wanna see.
Wanna see them dancing, walking around on those...
What do you call them?
Feet!
Flipping your fins you don't get to...
Strolling along down a...
What's that word again?
Up where they run.
Ponder and dream.
Wish I could be part of them.
Or I could live out of these waters.
What would I pay?
But children, they understand.
That they don't reprimand their daughters.
Bright young women, sick of swimming.
Ready to stand.
And ready to know what the people know.
Ask them my questions and get some answers.
What's a fire?
And why does it...
What's the word?
Burn?
When's it my turn?
Wouldn't I love, love to explore that shore up above?
Out of the sea.
Wish I could be part of that world.
I'm sorry, I had a flashback I think.
A silly clip I saw of this song.
And I couldn't stop laughing about it.
Yeah, me too.
What does this have to do with Metal Gear?
The voice of Eva is the voice of Ariel.
Little Mermaid.
So honestly, you can make an AMV...
Or a VM... VMV?
Video music video.
Wait, video game...
VGMV.
Video game music video.
Of Eva with this song.
Wait, what?
Yeah!
It was revealed officially.
Just like this month.
Isn't that crazy?
MGSVMV.
It was recently revealed.
Eva is a Disney princess.
Princess and the Frog.
Yeah!
I'll sing every Disney.
Princess and the Frog.
Wait, I wrote...
I wrote the wrong thing.
And then I think I'm just gonna...
Force quit OBS or something.
This will be our outro music for today.
This will be our ending.
Princess and the Frog will be it.
And it's not my style.
Oh, that's Frogbert?
But I know exactly where I'm going.
Getting closer and closer every day.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
People down here think I'm crazy.
But I don't care.
Trials and tribulations.
I've had my share.
There ain't nothing gonna stop me now.
Because I'm almost there.
To Canada!
Woo!
I remember Daddy told me.
Fairy tales can come true.
You gotta make them happen.
It all depends on you.
So I work real hard each and every day.
And things are for sure going my way.
Just look.
Oh, I just fell over there.
And I messed it up.
I'm almost there.
People gonna come here from everywhere.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
There's been trials and tribulations.
You know I've had my share.
But I've climbed a mountain.
I've crossed a river.
And I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
I can't hold it.
TASK MANAGER!
Otsumita!
Bye bye!
End task.
Goodbye!